Frederic Henry was an American ambulance driver...
...serving in the Italian army during World War I.
He met Catherine Barkley, an English nurse's aide.
Henry was wounded in battle and brought to a hospital in Milan to recover.
Catherine joined him there, to help him get better.
They soon passionately fell in love, and Catherine became pregnant.
Henry was again sent to the front lines of battle.
His troops were forced to retreat, and Henry was almost killed.
He escaped from his unit and returned to Milan, looking for Catherine.
He reunited with her in the town of Stresa in Italy.
From there, they once again escaped to Switzerland...
...where they could live happily and peacefully.
Early one morning in the spring,...
...Catherine went to the hospital to give birth.
She delivered a stillborn baby boy and, later that night,...
...died of a hemorrhage.
Henry stayed at her side until she was gone.
He walked back to his hotel in the rain.